Kruja vësht njunga qutejtë të mëtë përmendura në historinën shqiptarve.
Qutejtë ishtritë në shpatinë e malitë të krujës në lërthsinë gjashqinë të të mejtrën bini velinë e detit.
Gërmimet arkeologike në kështjela në krujës dëshmojnë se vendi ka qënë venbani milir që prej shhekullit të tredë paralindje se krištitë.
Gjetja atëju e një vendi më tëmbrojturë për banore të bëri që kruja të merterënë si për gjith krahinën si qenderë e kulturës arbërëshë,
ashtu si që dëshmojnë edhe objekte të një vareze të shhekullit të gjashë derin në shhekullin e të edhe.
Kruja përmendet përher të parë në një dokument të vitit të 179 si qenderë peshkopatë.
Më tëj, ajëmbe të qenderë e garnizoneve dhe guvernatorve bizantin deri në funë të shhekullit dëmbëdhjedh.
Kruja ishte epi qenderë e shtetit të parë feudal shqiptarë 1119 dhe dhjedh, 1255 dhe dhjedh.
Quteti arriti lulzimin në shhekullin 13 dhjedh, 14 dhjedh.
Në gjusme në dhjut të shhekullit 14 dhjedh, kruja ishte kruje qenderë e topiajve me tregeti e zaitari të zhvilluarë.